in regards to torrent there isn't much
that were given on him we know he's been
through the ringer with previous owners
who are trying to go on this long
journey of achieving the ultimate goal
of reaching the Eldon ring along this
path he must have met with Melena and
Ronnie as they are the only two other
characters that even reference the
existence of torrent and he chooses us
to be the next one to go on this journey
with also have you noticed that torrent
has a scar under his left eye along with
some pretty serious burns on his left
side remind you of anybody else I think
torrent has been around a very long time
and as a spirit he's likely looking for
the final path back to the ERD tree so
that he can move on to whatever comes
next I think this is the biggest lore
reason why we can't use torrent during
the final boss fight even though the
Eldon beast fight is total dog and
is very much improved if you can use
torrent to run down the eldenbeast when
he swims away like you can in the
convergence mod